rio boa noite pra geral
prometo falar pouco por vários motivos
primeiro que a produção de discos aos
seis minutos a equipa da galera foi
bronze
queria saber se é real e é só seis
minutos já tô gastando 1
às vezes vou falar rapidamente até
porque é é a última apresentação e tal
finalizar um evento desse pra nós não
tem como a gente chega aqui e não
agradecer e agora realmente não sei o
que eu estou fazendo aqui depois ela
falou isso me identifiquei mesmo que
quando eu cheguei também a mãe
vou fazer uma palestra ela falou eu até
estou primeiro depois falou essa roupa
está muito legal mas beleza fortalecer a
ideli e cheguei aqui não na portaria
tudo bom cara de sério né todo mundo que
cara de sério eu vim fazer uma palestra
ou quais somam de palestrante deu biro
biro biro biro biro
bom então caro não tem nem como falar
assim
é desse evento todo mundo tá aqui ó que
teve a oportunidade única de presenciar
seres humanos espetaculares e que não
sei nem poderia chamar seres humanos são
pessoas alienígenas e que estão fazendo
uma parada como eu tenho tempo é é o
tempo é reduzido o gol só falou uma
palavra muito importante a galera do
barulho cara fiquei emocionado porque eu
já fui lá no fernando tá ligado
e na época achava que eu sei mas não
consegue marcar hoje mas na época achava
que sabia riman
eu lembro que tinha humana que
trabalhava lá que a paulista não sei se
ele mostrar trabalho ainda hoje
o irmão foi mas o total e tal cara pauli
sotaque forte e tal aí fui professor da
faculdade na época ele falou pô fácil
buscar aí fica aquela vozinha assim mas
excelente possível desenvolvido aqui há
pouco que lhes valeu senão vou ter que
fingir que é excelente
- quem disse não ter que fingir chegar
até agora era o pole não há irmão
botei fé no potencial aí segue pelo
sonho e tal
e a gente está falando aqui de som de
possibilidade e de possibilidades nesse
período
assim como é o nosso apresentação a
gente faz freestyle a rima de improviso
a gente gosta de falar um pouco só para
quem será às vezes não é muito
familiarizado com a parada e tal a rimas
de improviso ela se assemelha muito ao
aos dados de repente do nordeste o que
difere a parte instrumental no nordeste
eles usam viola sanfona é às vezes uma
métrica poética diferenciada a gente usa
é bits instrumentais de músicas do hip
hop tal a falando um pouco da batalha do
neurônio mas não só dela me sinta que é
11 mil de representantes de todas as
batalhas do distrito federal e do
entorno que acontecem várias quebradas
várias cidades satélites e e do entorno
também ea gente acredita nisso como mais
do que a propagação da cultura hip hop a
ocupação do espaço público com cultura e
é acaba sendo tudo que um pouco do que a
galera falou que se a corrente do bem é
você vai para a praça você faz a rima
você serve de exemplo um cara você diz e
mina é a curiosidade de procurar e você
desperta quando você pode propiciar
novos talentos e tal e aí a gente aqui a
gente acredita muito nisso na ocupação
dos espaços públicos com arte com rima e
acho que estou falando demais e vai ter
que imaginar o que o o o cronômetro e
começou a contar a batalha do dom orani
é uma batalha de conhecimento é uma
batalha temática e tal é as pessoas
sugerem rimas elas mostram objetos o que
vocês vão fazer daqui a pouco já está
entregando aqui na batalha tradicional
geralmente seu objetivo é usuária
adversário usuários têm que entender de
negri ofender fazer piada e tal
aqui a gente não tá muito assim que
fazer com vocês claro mas está aqui mais
educação e foi convidado a receber o
lanche água porque isso dá moral
cléo sinceramente queijo uma limpa eu
falo demais eu juro que isso que eu falo
não foi só eu tô fazendo stand up que
sem querer que estão indo dar certo eu
falei e não quero sair da equipe é
melhor não espera espera espera aí
mas a melhor parte nunca foi essa que
foi o que eu fiz mas é melhor para se
viver
agora que é do que a dos meus camaradas
improvisando mc enézimo disse marin é lá
atrás da alma humana e missy meleca
levantei me leva pra todo mundo te ver
cara
o sol é não que a gente esteja puxando
sardinha mc meleca
ele foi um cara que começou a fazer
improviso na batalha do museu que
acontece no museu da república as todo
todos os domingos às quatro da tarde
seja tão mais do que intimados nem
convidados intimados a dar um pulo lá e
tal todos os domingos tem essa batalha e
ele começou a cobrir é no início de
maneira até precária com o celular zinho
as batalhas e postado no canal deles do
youtube e hoje o canal dele tem mais de
13 milhões de acessos se chama meleca
vídeos nada mais justo e es e ele cobre
todas as batalhas é do distrito federal
e entorno quem quiser também saber mais
sobre um pouco do trabalho só acessá la
bom já falei demais queria agradecer
agradecer todos os palestrantes dizer
que quer tirar foto com você estourada
barulho professora gina a aparência do
xingamento estava no meu deus não fala
muito palavrão que isso voltei para
ficar e se mexeu comigo sempre
mas não vou parar de falar é nela que
está tudo certo aí a gente vai fazer
três sessões de improviso a primeira só
de apresentação pra vocês já em leiria
como é que funciona se aquecerem quem
tiver assim sentir o clima foi bom
sentir a energia já está acabando já
pode soltar a franga pode gritar
levantar a mão falar assim nossa saída
foi dura faz barulho e tal porque assim
a gente pagou caro por esses dois
meninos estarem aqui fazendo rima pra
vocês então por favor estou brincando aí
meleca só do bié vai ser uma rima de
apresentação e depois vai ser uma das
hashtags que vocês soltaram que no final
se hei hei
então tá bom primeiramente boa noite pra
geral queria um pouco de volume no
instrumental poderia estar falando
palavras
o isolamento mas aprendi que não a
palestra do xingamento então tá bom eu
vou falar pato madeira com certeza bola
na barulhenta então vou chegar a minha
presentes o marinho e vou passar a bola
ali logo por nezinho até ligado na mala
até não jogar até o fim
marieta colado prazer cm se nem se eu
faço a minha rima e se eu admiro mas não
agüento mais escutadas do mano me viro
ele fala demais
acha que é amor isso mas eu prefiro
humano que é fisiculturista porque meu
barco sai do meu pique aqui na rima que
não vai mandando em cima desse vídeo
concordo alienígena na moral mas onde
repousaram anápio pessoal porque não dá
para entender onde vai estacionar
assistir à palestra com isso não vou me
preocupar em vai se preocupar isso é de
repente porque eles vêem o mesmo é
somente usando a mente porque chega um
dia bem mais longe em 47 rimaro
tranquilo igual mostra eu estou pensando
é mesmo do marmitex poderia estar
fugindo dos cana do giroflex mas não foi
só aqui ao vivo no t 10 mandando e
províncias e sabe se repete
estou aqui fazendo rima do pedex mas eu
estou indignado como a compra que não
chegou a pelo sedex
mas sabe o que eu liguei para o alex é o
melhor é que trouxe até um sabor protex
então pode parar nem falou demais agora
eu vou continuar de zero que não podia
voar mas não parece patrick estrela tem
que concordar de moré setor ligado na
rima até 100 kms e patrick agora tudo a
cila agora aparece nu para se arranjar
esquilo só vai enfrentar
é o lixo
dando certo adams an o número supera que
é todo decorado mano eu colaborei falei
que era para fingir que é dar certo e se
fingiu de mais do que isso aí não vi tal
sr mas de improviso e tal
só que assim para quem acha que não foi
combinado que estava ali no cantinho a
gente tem um desafio da hashtag que
foram restritos que foram sendo colhidas
ao longo do dia pela organização da tec
e tal
aqui da unb e agora a missão é mais
complicada a gente é as hashtags vão
aparecendo aqui e aí os exames vão se
virando vamos fazer um improviso e tal e
aí e está no critério de vocês continuar
fingindo que estão gostando e tal
o senhor é parte do combinado entendeu
mas vou deixar de falar aí meleca salto
beach assim que a gente tem com a
presença já pode começar a se virar ii
que estou até com medo uma hei de amor
ai quando o amor é agora acelera
pressionam a 30 cm cic essa esfera mas
ele é fera porque era arrimo a gente
chegar ao beijar e manda na empresa
espera pelo espelho na outra hashtag
minha inspiração é coloca os mesmos e
fazer rap mais perto mais um para poder
filmar esperando ainda não vai mandar a
principal diferença aqueles que faz 18
que sabem marcar presença quem vem fazer
sua sequência porque quero ver neymar
imensa ter inteligência falou demais
agora é minha vez e vou mostrar coisas
que nem sempre foi kei seu poderia está
fazendo terrorismo mas não estou
aprendendo um pouco de empreendedorismo
segue com a série pode
a gente chegou ea gente veio pra rimar
então tá bom eu vou raciocinar não tinha
neurônio mas serviu foi pra pensar ah e
eu vou continuar porque eu vou chegar
maluco e prosseguir podia discutir podia
até finge mas aprendi que a violência
não cola bem aqui
o amor é amor é aí que o solo vocês vão
pensar o que consegui aqui é não
procedeu é desse jeito eu vou mandá lo
só pra perceber tá escrito legaliza
pergunto legalize o que eu não vou
fazendo aqui no fim eu ia falar
legalistas e quem esquece
é desse jeito nem sei que vai chegar eu
rimando aqui e é só pra constar porque a
gente faz e aí meu idioma e 10 divididas
mais unido a gente soma e é desse jeito
a gente segue vem chamando vez seguindo
na rima improvisando e assim tem sal e 9
não pereça momentos igual e sapé e
agradeço em em aaa a aa
eu não esqueço você já percebeu eu tenho
um sonho seu paulo moro qual é o seu o
meu é crescer em mandar brasa eu sou e
venda mas sorri quando eu chegar em casa
mas é tem o feminismo mas se sabe meu
marido também que tem que ser longe do
machismo também hoje do racismo mas
também não pode ficar na beira do abismo
você tem que pensar porque sem a previ
momento eu me atrevo fazendo mostrando
meu talento no movimento pode ser que
tem neto mas a chave da atitude ao
conhecimento porque eu quero essa
vitória mas eu também quero escrever
minha história não quero bem só para
ficar na minha memória eu quero um dia
alcançar com deus a glória bem demorou
cadê o tema mobilidade urbana por aqui a
6 é problema
ó eu falo sem carro foi [ __ ] pra poder
chegar aqui de metrô
então tá bom
o hotel fica na minha mas eu quero me my
o menino
minha eu sou músico promec manda demais
mas é nova brasília construída com muita
paz e conseguir moedas rapaz novos
aprendizados rejeite 20 mais tentador
agora se que é estar ligado no leque
bote fé um quadro já encheu não tenho
que falar eu acho que vou sair na
platéia se a posso falar porque
recusando ter cabelo bené demasia me
olhando no espelho prossigo e que isso é
improviso porque me tirou da beira do
abismo então tá valendo
deixo meu aviso pra nós não tem preço
que vale o seu sorriso
o
o ouro olímpico
quem descobre no seu estudo
aí quem mais faz barulho aí só isso e os
ips e tal a gente estão feijão é bem
mais que isso
ae na verdade quem tiver um objeto tem
como levantar pra nós encol o mogi ele
estiver preso na moral estou decidindo
machista mas mandaram se sentiu mal com
a go proc
ei tabelou com uma américa pode acertar
a base que nós é desse jeito pode
começar e morou e morreu
aí peguei proíba artista passe a começar
a carreira 3
então tá bom agora que vou começar não
sei se o raciocínio pensando é fácil vá
então tá bom
na rima nunca para foi bater no lese mas
é sua de bengala então tá vendo maluco
aqui que não avançar
eu vou e mano já vejo é uma escova mas
eu tô vendo e fácil apelo eu até usaria
só que eu não tenho cabelo mas aqui é
diferente empréstimo marinha essa pasta
de dentes a roda e isso me incomoda é a
pressa essa pasta para guardar a j
porque na rima eu quero sentimento
interno eu quero escrever minha vida num
caderno porque eu tenho um foco mais e
pb1 água depois levada ocorre que beber
muita água preciso falar mais de três
meses para poder se hidratar
eu vou falar digo com sinceridade ela
não é indigência ela corta a identidade
é essa que vem fazendo eu cheguei aqui
ao vivo e vou desenvolvendo no mundo que
eu vivo nada falta demorou esqueça tudo
em casa - um carregador
então eu vou falar pode crer nessa
pegada a gente vai continuar
então tá bom você sabe que eu não vou
parar aquele livres que tocava o tolouse
passa pra lá
o temor é rei ei ó e quando eu oro e faz
sua luz pra jesus e as militava da de
souza cruz estadão a todos silva crimes
é o pai
mas aqui na minha remar minha mente não
me trai porque eu falo a 40 é de olhar a
data 13 26 1990 porque é desse jeito que
nós faz a mente vai provando que somos
bem mais capaz bem biro pode rimar é sua
bebê humano já pode improvisar o volante
improvisado afirmação é falsa o sapato é
35 no número que você calça infelizmente
desse jeito a proceder
eu vou chegar vivo até ter que devolver
e eu vou mandar nenhum verso é cabuloso
cara filme a mãe possa meu filho ficou
famoso e esse revés seguido
e é desse jeito feliz aqui não vai
diminuindo então que assim seja eu vi
cinco garrafas ao meu pé mas nenhuma de
cerveja aí eu fico pensando que depois
do pr é pra que a gente tá aí caminho
narriman atacou vi a bola de beisebol
microfone arrumei facul e eu ataco assim
que vou falar já que tomava rakineh
vírus chega pra lá muita calma que eu
vou ter que explicar falar que a
organização depois do evento vai bancar
leão pp ba serão já vai colar
então sabendo aqui agora vou explicar
demorou agora pra compreender e quem
quiser fortalecer comprar um cd porque
eu falo hoje não tem desconto pra ajudar
o gás só pode pagar é desconto e eu vou
falar
não tô à toa o nome do cd é viver o
crítico menor que rua mas olha só eu
voltei pra vocês é nós que vez somos
somente sonhos mais uma vez a casa caiu
mas hoje a casa vai brincar porque um
lugar só eu quero buscar eu tenho uma
atitude eu quero a minha vida o giro no
fundão rimando a cada batida avisa que
tem questão de tempo é o que eu sempre
quis mesmo foi solto fé porque eu quero
ter a fé que minha estrela me conduza o
que eu quero ser uma coisa que minha
mente usa pra crescer também podem
entender
esse cd é [ __ ] vai saber porque meu
marido eu vou falar na humildade
não sei se sou [ __ ] total
responsabilidade respeito daquele jeito
logo que eu aceito a calma agora ele não
tem feito
op isso aqui não tem preço [ __ ] assim o
choro modo de coração agradeço
valeu valeu valeu valeu valeu a reunião
no bunker e isso não é teu e na época
ela que cheguei
ou eu estou me sentindo no maracanã é
dar um tchau tchau tchau tchau tchau
tchau saber é que sei ainda pode parar
de gravar é pode pode pode pode botar no
bolso ela vai lá lhe valeu galera muito
barulho como é que o nosso dj jorge por
favor por favor
valeu valeu valeu só explicar mas que
minha mãe fortalecer o pendrive hoje
para traçar instrumental ela ficou
bolada que apagar pasta do sesi uma
missão foi cumprida e trouxemos beach
rolou tudo certo e é nóis é então nós
temos o nosso tempo acabou ea mina da
organização está bem aqui do radar e que
já pediu a gostar mas assim não tenho
nem o que falar só queria agradecer
imensamente decoração e nome de todos os
cristaleiros de brasília aqui não só 24
tem muito humano que está nesse corre
tem muito humano que faz em prol da
própria quebrada tem muito humano que
tem uma visão de espalhar essa corrente
do bem através da rima da arte da poesia
da literatura da música e assim
compartilhar com vocês aqui não tem nem
o que falar fico muito emocionado de ver
onde que o hip hop está chegando e é um
cara do gama não está aqui mais mas
porque estava na palestra ele falou mano
que já deu parece nova iorque botamos do
racionais eu queria gritar falar motor
cabuloso na moral e legal mas pouco todo
mundo aqui é [ __ ] muito obrigado de
coração pelo convite
o mesmo valeu comemorou é só pra deixar
bem claro também é uma forma de
agradecimento ao irmão ali ele falou que
quando ele perdeu a perna pedir para ele
o aroma é o nome do novo cd não esquivou
que já tentaram derrubar a gente várias
vezes mas a gente preferiu buscar os
nossos sonhos e deus abençoe tá puxando
o nosso vôo e é isso obrigado